with 120 missile strikes
um which appear to be a mixture of these
ballistic missiles but also the drones
that have been recently brought in from
Iran
um from Land and Sea that have targeted
across the country it's yes a further
wave of attacks all of which seem to be
targeting critical National energy
infrastructure uh across the country of
course without getting inside uh Putin's
head it's very difficult to know exactly
what's going on but what looks most
likely is that two things really one of
which is Russia as militarily stalled on
the ground and is desperately Keen to um
to distract the ukrainians from their
war effort and of course by attacking
energy infrastructure the weather's not
very nice here in the UK but it's
fearsely cold in in Ukraine and by
knocking out the energy it's making life
really unpleasant particularly for
people in in the capital Kiev and and
all of this is almost certainly designed
to undermine support for president
zielinski and try to erode that support
and make put pressure on him to perhaps
start to negotiate the other bit that I
think almost certainly is that it won't
have escaped Putin's attention that
Patriot missile systems have been
promised by America to Ukraine they will
take some while to get into country and
be positioned and of course as soon as
they arrive it'll be a lot more
difficult for the particular ballistic
missile attacks to be effective anywhere
where Patron is based so I think Russia
will be Keen to take whatever impact
they can before the arrival of that
Western military system